[Music]
apparent signs of ukraine fighting back
military sources claim an offensive
operation against russian forces in the
south is underway
though details are slim
anyone want to know what our plans are
you won't hear specifics from any truly
responsible person because this is war
and this is how it is during the war
but the occupiers should know we will
push them to the border
the port city of hassan would be a key
prize
it was captured with ease in the initial
days of russia's war and has been under
russian control ever since
any move against the occupation will be
high risk and will rely heavily on
western weapons
while the start of this operation is an
important moment ukraine is a vast
country and so is the front line with
multiple flash points even as ukrainian
forces are trying to regain ground in
one area they're coming under pressure
in others including most dangerously
around a key nuclear plant in the
southeastern region of zapposia
this is the place
it's been under russian control since
march
but clashes in the area have triggered
fears of a nuclear disaster on top of
the military one a double nightmare for
those living nearby
even as a team of international nuclear
inspectors prepares to pay the plant a
visit
allah and her husband have their lives
squashed into this boot
their town sits on the opposite bank of
a river to the nuclear plant
but russian shelling forced the couple
to start camping at night in this field
about 10 miles away
the strain all too
down the road another makeshift campsite
filled with fear these two families also
come from mahanet's town
they say the russian attacks have been
getting worse over the past few days
stop going back into town with her
daughter during the day and is working
out what to do next
scares you the most the war or the
potential for a nuclear disaster
[Music]
it's terrible for little emma too
but her mum's doing all she can to
protect her from the trauma
debra haynes sky news southern ukraine